welcome to this video round two of the
Norway chess tournament yeah and I'll
gandu him format where present for games
briefly of the five games and then one
game with a little bit more detail yeah
the first round had only one winner
kawana was winning as black against
greece shocked who blundered in time
trouble and must apologize i am had a
wrong impression about the time control
of this tournament it is actually a non
increment time control where an
increment is only implemented after move
61 so we have two hours for 40 moves one
hour for 20 moves and then they get an
additional I think 15 minutes plus the
increment yeah fine time control but
what I really wonder is it really
necessary that nowadays every tournament
has a different time control I mean all
the time you ask yourself what are they
playing and even if the father think
about leaked chess i'm playing a german
league belgium leak and dutch leak and
we all have different time controls and
every time i need to ask my team camp in
there or what do what again what's the
time control again and what what's so
difficult to just establish one time
control and play by that i understand
that for some tournaments where you have
a limited time schedule like you need to
play two rounds a day that you don't
play 28 our games as somewhat somewhat
clear but why not form for typical games
just establish a single time control and
kill with that okay anyway let's say go
to the games and i must say that there
was lots of interesting content today at
the end I chose some the game kiwanis
witla as the game that it will present
in somewhat more detail but there also
are other interesting points in the
other games i'll start with the
relatively least
interesting game this is odd cast on the
second norwegian play and the tournament
playing onigiri um yeah cast on here
goes for d4 he also plays Aoife is a
quite versatile play and the openings
and they got them this Queens gambit
Rogozin or sometimes also called the
Westphalia variation I'm place the
somewhat rare move Queen a 4 here Stein
and then the direct consequences that we
have some trades and simplification yeah
here we are pretty quickly coming to a
position where black has an isolated
pawn okay it's not the terrible weakness
but Dwight has a nice blockading square
oops a nice blockading square here and
no particular problems yeah and it
turned out that after some more moves we
actually had this position with the sea
porn switching over 24 and after some
more trades the position became really
totally equal this was a thing a fine
effort by by an active Stein who never
was in any trouble here against the
strong Dutch am a junior player I don't
think he's really formally a junior
anymore with I think it's 1900 Giri but
still still young yeah so um a pretty
much uneventful draw I'd say but I think
I kristin is pretty uncomfortable with
that um okay the next game let's look at
crumb Nick Collison yeah not in modern
classic this encounter they always have
interesting games this time it started
very young Chan yeah with a very solid
opening cards in here playing the sort
of catch
then bogu hybrid we directly go to a to
a Catalan sorry a blog Indian position
with Bishop before and the capture only
to this is um this kind of setup is a
very solid way to play as black and in
fact cards and has played this a number
of times already also against ramnik he
even beat chronic in exactly this line
in wagons a oh no it gets tricky 2000mm
nine ten it's been a year but in a few
years back but he managed to win this
kind of structures black against crony
which I found really remarkable yeah and
in this game we also had the the typical
play that that arises here the C file is
important and wide at the end managed to
to open the position and after some
trades we go here I thought when I was
briefly i'm looking at this during the
the life play thought okay white has a
little something but it shouldn't be
anything dramatic in fact it turned out
that relatively quickly I got the whole
queenside traded off and yeah at first
you think okay this is going to end in a
quick draw but it's not it's not that
straightforward because there are still
some ideas of a text with the Queen and
night being a nice combined attacking
force white has this idea of attacking
like that and black has those kind of
ideas and waiting with the Queen so
there are some things that that are
still going on and in fact there was an
interesting moment if we look at this
position here after Queen d5 the first
idea that you naturally have what about
the check here jack now this was
interesting King of course and now night
f7 first you think okay maybe this is
somewhat a Kia Queen age eight but after
Queen h8 King g6 if we imagine this
position there is not even a check
the Dwight can play so black now can set
up some strong threats after night f7 ya
think of Queen f3 for example this um
can can be quite tricky now the funny
thing is this position is in fact a
force draw because white has an
absolutely amazing way to play and I g5
check takes that Queen g6 and this is a
really Stanley a really great stalemate
then this isn't is just a beautiful
white has three pawns here and do four
pawns they're all blocked by the king by
the Queen and by the pin and the King
also has no move so it's just the draw
by stalemate black after his check and
can of course draw back in then we get
this stalemate so it's a just a very
very funny a variation ok kramnik mmm it
didn't do that he played f4 and term
after a couple of moves it sent that
black is making some progress black is
the more active site IAM and in fact it
for a moment really looked like maybe
Magnus's again managing to press some
yeah water out of stone but night f5
p.m. gave away upon and white managed to
get into this end game queen and came
upon down which very often is it's lost
frankly speaking a queen ending with the
pawn down but in this case there is a
six and this is very important why this
directly this was chrome legs idea
directly going for counter play after
the capture check the white queen gives
check and enters the position like that
adhere white has this oops this idea of
a perpetual with Queen to g5 or queen j8
and blacks only way to prevent the
perpetual is too
do it like that go back with the Queen
and after that white gets the six pawn
and this is really just the draw because
the white green has such a active
position it's very difficult to like to
even try for anything in the game
they're relatively quickly traded off as
some more stuff and here agreed to a
draw of course there's absolutely
nothing left on the board so a really
tough fight where at one point I
actually thought that maybe Magnus is
getting somewhere but it ended in a draw
ok the next game to look at is Aronian
or the sky aachen and here we get a
Queen's Indian kayaking is really one of
the few players in top-level chess who
has some a relatively narrow opening
repertoire he branches out only very
rarely with some stuff he normally does
not play the Queen's in unison his some
absolute main defense of course paired
with the names 0 for as long as I can
remember and we we get a typical Queens
Indian position here after some can we
can really let's do this relatively
quickly here we get this fairly typical
position this can arise out of many one
default openings or sometimes even out
of English openings territory with the
CND portrayed it happens now here this
is a really am really normal very often
seen structure where normally why it has
a very slight pool because he will post
up this night on e5 and it's very
important to know it and that black has
I don't know why this keeps happening
why that black has those two pawns
played it's really a big difference if
the Pawn would be on on b7 for example
or both pawns would be back on be seven
and eight seven
then the important c6 weakness is not
it's not a problem and here it is a
problem black here really has to be very
precise in defense it's simply somewhat
passive and he tries immediately to to
get rid of one of the week pawns the
problem is however if we look at this
position now that yeah black has gone
rid of this but still c6 this week if
you look at this kind of moves and there
is the a pawn which is also still a
problem white also has two pawns against
one those some ponds IAM against a 6mm
whiten has chances to get a free porn
and a passport yeah we am continued here
for one and a for this i really didn't
like this really gives white the passer
right away and if around here black cam
has managed to get himself into an a
really uncomfortable end game with white
having the be porn play against the a3
porn yeah and the more active night we
got those knives exchange with white has
one upon and this end game here is
probably impossible to defend though it
maybe wasn't the the best resistance
possible that k aachen i'll manage to
put we it's a bit tricky now in this
quick replay to to look at at some finer
points it's a it's for example here I
think it's questionable if he really
should trade the rook he could have
taken on b6 as well and allow wide to
check here I really thought this would
be somewhat tougher defense then
allowing the sea porn here to stay on
the board this at least lamb symptom
yeah very hopeless to me but I only
looked at this briefly because while I
decided to do another game in more
detail and if I
do am super deep analysis of all games I
never get anywhere I only thought myself
well is this the best defense I don't
call it the proper analysis um maybe
this really wasn't a better defense to
to get rid to to take the pass end and
avoid this type of situation here where
white is now advancing with the King and
just promotes that promotes the pawn
yeah k i Ken resigned he will simply and
need to allow the promotion now I'm so
important to win here form aronian and
yeah a tough game for hey I can you
always was somewhat worse and those kind
of positions are often the most
difficult to defend um okay we have the
power of playing gree shock and we have
a funny opening sequence IAM to pile of
playing Knight to f3 Grisha playing c5
p.m. has studied this kind of variation
very very deeply and scored very nicely
with this line but the bottle of place
before it goes back into it Sicilian of
course to part of is also one for player
so it's not a huge thing for them to to
transpose like that yeah they got an ID
off and another cue to move all the
issue Bishop e3 is answered by Knight g4
Bishop c1 and black drop back just
asking why there what exactly are you
going to do you want to draw yeah of
course the pile of does not want to draw
place h3 I mean it's the question if
chris scherk really would have played a
draw I think they have some sort of end
time draw rule in place okay h3 which is
one of the topical lines and they got it
typically sharp Sicilian position
wyd went for long castles black went
from short castles and we have the the
situation that is so typical for the for
the Sicilian with the opposite sides
castling both sides try to attack why
this activating is rupiah on the
third-ranked trying to use the challenge
III and the nidus zone is in an
aggressive position on f5 but also note
there is a night on sea for him and a
bit shibani of 60 black has very decent
um pieces as well to to get some counter
play um yeah I think this was a really
complicated and double-edged game um if
we look a bit before the White has lost
the porn but it didn't really matter
because law look at this white still has
an enormous amount of activity like here
I rook f3f 7 as a threat you know this
is also why f5 was played directly
attacking the Queen and even after the
Queen trade white still had some some
big pressure for the pawn around here I
think the position is probably around
equal as White's pressure should always
be enough to to be at least equal yeah
deform was played young activating and
attacking here on c3 and in fact the
whole game comes down to exactly this
position where now topalov should have
taken really on on I first you first it
is i'm sorry i forgot to insert those
yeah here exactly here he am made him a
move that turns out to be a big mistake
he should have just taken on f5 and
played this position which seems to be
okay if there is nothing terribly great
that black can do we can take here for
example
and we could have reached this position
with some should be okay for why there's
nothing terribly bad happening we need
to continue this line with rookie one
intending 90 to check but it does not
seem to be a be fatal white can even
play the funny move naija form and this
is can for example okay for white as the
night is coming here and get this
counter play going against the Queen
side just one line the problem is he
played rook f.2d three and he still had
some time on his clock um just to assess
this mistake better because it really is
a fatal mistake after rook to e3 now we
shall played 95 and this move while
looking yeah nothing much at first is in
fact very strong because Black now has
two threats he threatens Bishop to have
form and this cuts off the night on age
six yeah if the night on age six here is
disconnected from the bishop 1c1 then
white will lose this piece it's almost
trapped on the side of the board this is
one threat and the other thread is
Knights e2 e3 which would attack the
rukon d1 and attack the night on age six
so those two threats actually win
outright why it has no defense against
that he played this and now Bishop f4
was played and the night is really
trapped white only can take play dumb
crook f3 him yeah and at first you think
wait is this so clear what exactly is
happening if the night moves away maybe
you can take f5 c4 is hanging hmm is
this so clear through this position as a
small exercise and stop the video blah
to play and win there is more than one
move that that wins but there is one
move that is especially strong and wins
like immediately so on I'll be silent
for a couple of seconds so that you can
conveniently pause the video all right I
will continue now and the move that wins
the game and the move that was played
back we shook as a very beautiful move
rookie one and this is really a totally
nice white only can take room what what
else is there rook takes you one and
then they we have 90 to check and Knight
f3 and this is very nice now this rook
is a tech and at the same time the night
on h6 attacked and there is absolutely
no defense that white also has no move
to attack one of the nights yeah
theoretically speaking you can you can
try that but then there is the next one
attacking f1 and still your tag age 60
why does losing the size of material
here it's very very nice so after rookie
one here after this this really the same
a blow of a new rookie one to palaver
yeah certainly very disappointed
resigned yeah very complicated game and
this time gree shock was the not the
luckier one but certainly the more alert
one the morn yeah the sharper one in the
in the time trouble we're in comparison
to round one when with very little time
on the clock yet blundered against
kawano ok so I spent some time on the
other games but they were interesting
points in there let's go for the main
thing of this video Caruana swidler yeah
and um I mean I needed to do the game
because it was just so
so insanely complicated and interesting
but the one thing I need to to say right
away this is the kind of game where if
it would have been played like 30 years
ago before we are we we had the
computers and chess and chess engines it
would have been absolutely impossible to
to do any sort of verdict on like a
couple of hours after the game because
it was so immensely complicated that for
human you would have taken hours to even
get close to some sort of truth um and
all what I'm going to present this is
basically coming coming out of the
engine it's it's it's it's all it cannot
give any input to it because it's so
complicated okay let's let them move to
them to the most em they are the most
interesting positions it's with less
playing the Sicilian the time man of
variation that's actually a debatable if
this really should be caught a mile off
maybe it should be called polzin time on
off really am really invented this kind
of setup but okay it's normally call
time on of even with Queen c7 yeah okay
Kara wanna is going for this sharp set
up with the long castling the typical
English attack set up here white has
some not played f3 that early he first I
castled long and we get very typical
Sicilian play yeah why does some
counseling queenside spend one tempo on
King be one very often you simply need
to do it and now pushes with g4 yeah the
interesting thing about this particular
version of things you take is that black
still has some porn on d 7 which is not
so common in many Sicilians this means
here he sometimes
can play the typical counter-strike in
the center in one move d 75 not d65 on
the other end compared to some versions
of the english attack words evening and
order or the hay vonnegan even in him
yeah it's difficult or the night off
compared to this Black has played a
quick Quincy 7 which is also not
terribly useful in this in this
particular structure yeah we have this
typical stuff happening before is played
attacking the night and the night went
to a form yeah it's always a tricky
question in the Sicilian after before
when the night is attacked where do you
go in this particular case 92 is of
course somewhat strange decision as you
would give up your important bishop so 9
a-4 is played and yeah the night on a
40m is also not so badly placed it
sometimes looks at the b6 Square and it
cannot be attacked so easily okay
theoretically speaking you can attack it
with the Queen at some point but b3 is
always a good response to that this
night is not going to get lost you know
Queenie fibers are also very silly move
but just in general the night is not so
bad them yeah black played h6 spending
one move to make sure that the night is
not a form of six I mean the night here
does not need to retreat to a very bad
square on the edge of the board if we
look at castles for example after g5
yeah you need to go to age 5 or 38 and
both do not look totally a.m. yeah
totally harmonious there are ideas
sometimes with 96 even but not sure he
played age 62 to stew to stop this for
the moment rook g1 plate and now d5 a
typical typical counter stroke um if we
look at the databases
it seems that we are already on new
territory at least I didn't find the
game with this particular position yeah
and it gets super sharp now absolutely
quickly we see by the clock times that
both players were unfamiliar ground
Bishop f4 takes and g5 so they both play
very quickly aiming for this position it
seems that they had this on the board
arm yeah close to that yeah and now we
get to a crisis in very short order
night ft 7 rook takes g7 and he takes f3
this already you look 20 minutes almost
20 minutes for the capture which I find
quite quite curious because well when
you enter this type of line which is of
course um yeah as sharp as it can get ya
black is having the King in the center
only eight he will never ever castle
maybe maybe long castle but hmm it's
also not not apparent how this should
happen quickly I find it weird that
after he takes a three years start to
doubt start to think or before that move
you start to think yeah and while this
position is already obviously very sharp
um karana now on yeah absolutely puts
more oil into the fire he took only six
and relatively quickly so it seems that
this was still started still part of his
preparation yes villain needs to take
this no choice he took it it took some
time this is quite interesting what else
is there they only move i briefly looked
at was Queen Queen to c6 but this after
94 Queen a four-night f5 um it's totally
deadly yeah 97
and queen d 6 yeah and I takes a 7 first
26 is completely decisive Black has no
defense yeah he he took it man I took
took a while for this but then he took
the took the night and kawana
immediately played Bishop d3 so all part
of the preparation yeah and this is of
course a very bad situation if you are
black here and you see that your
opponent is playing instant moves
obviously and knowing exactly what's
going on and you need to figure it out
over the board or at least sometimes it
can happen that those top players they
had it at at home but simply cannot
remember what exactly was the right move
okay but let's look at the position
itself and not speculate about any
things like preparation or whatnot yeah
what exactly is whiter threatening it is
really just just just check on g6 but
this is very very dangerous if we look
at some lines and the remarkable thing
is that if you look at it with the
computer and this is exactly the
position where I that are we was
referring to at the beginning of the
video with the computer you can in and
let's say 10 to 20 minutes at least
determine what is blacks probably what
is blacks best move as other moves do
lose but to find that out it's a it's
very very very difficult to do without a
computer's I would say I'm pretty much
yeah pretty much impossible task in a
limited time so let's check some moves
Bishop d7 for example in a normal move
yeah trying to coordinate black this is
not working simply due to the check yeah
and why is this so fatal the problem is
king d 8 is very simple white can just
take here and he's got 27 mate coming
yeah like black loses the house now
completely impossible and if King evade
is coming there is Luke
seven check which is the problem the
night takes white wins the Queen and
it's not just the Queen white is also
continuing to to attack black skin so
it's not just a material thing but also
too much in terms of the position yeah
and King g8 there is just 97 a rupee
seven sorry taking the night and black
ass busted you cannot really take 26 as
still the queen is lost yeah it just
it's just a simple win Bishop d7 is also
neglecting the the coverage of the d7
night yeah so what else if there I was
thinking maybe Queen d6 could be an idea
covering the bishop only seven this
however is answered by a move that is is
especially difficult to to find if you
try to do it by human means that Bishop
g6 is for example not so convincing look
at this check black can actually go to
g8 and right here white has no
particular great competitor great
continuation he basically must move the
Queen iam and black can even return some
material he M to continue to fight this
isn't totally clear but also not like
winning four wide it's um probably
somewhat better for black even however
here instead of the check white has an
immensely strong continuation and this
is Queen to e3 this is a super strong
move threatening Bishop g6 again with
also the rook being on the Queen and
after Queen III it seems that white is
winning but it's not easy at all if you
think of this King dat King gets out of
the check now White has a very strong
move Bishop
me too and exactly only this move other
moves are not enough and this is some it
seems winning for black / white I'm
sorry yeah a possible line if black girl
tries to save the queen no you just drop
back with the bishop and now I take e 5
yeah and this this is totally decisive
if black takes em check and why this is
going to meet ya there are this real
jungle of variations after after this
another another line that is quite nice
as Bishop f1 night c4 after that white
has Bishop g5 which is another important
detecting motif just double attacking e7
and this year check check check check
check mate it's a quite funny mate yeah
it's a really a jungle of variations
this is the critical position right
after the peace sacrifice what should
like flavor yeah it seems that the only
really playable move and move that the
computer ultimately assesses as equal
funny enough is the move rook to be
eight and why is this the only defense
it's very really tough really tough to
to even understand at first I thought
well what kind of move is this why
exactly should this be better than than
the others and there is in fact an
explanation for that the the point is
that after the check which is the most
obvious move not the only move but the
most obvious length after this we got
King d8 yeah and now the problem is if
we look at this there is a big
pin here of the night and this is also
pin if white now intensifies the
pressure with Queen to you three black
only has one move to actually prevent
white from taking and winning
immediately and this is rook b5 this is
the defensive idea rook b8 to be five
yeah so this is the big point behind the
rugby aid move and the the line now that
happens after this is really one of the
most insane lines i have seen in in
recent times and it's an it's an
absolute sequence of only move by both
sides that at the end will lead to a
draw it's really remarkable c4s the move
and the only one that really is good
here black needs to take ya know what
the rook does not have any any other
squares of you try to move it away their
c5 and black will explode here you
should take C fibers impossible to
prevent so the capture yeah Knight takes
yeah and here black here black in fact
has two moves but the the funniest one
is rook takes I to check it's a totally
crazy yeah King takes losers okay as
night see four picks up the Queen and at
the end Black will even have extra
material so you cannot take but you can
just play King to a keen to a one and
just say okay I'm still threatening
Bishop takes d5 what are you going to do
about it and it's remarkable black only
has one defensive move here but it is
enough rookie to totally crazy right
white can take it but this is the
absolutely only defense and that make
sure that now black has a tempo on the
rook so that you cannot play Bishop if I
for example yeah what exactly should
white
gather the line continues here probably
with rook takes the seven again being
the only move there should be some and
Bishop b5 and what's really remarkable
after something like let's say Quincy
five greentech see to that we have equal
material here after all these fireworks
we have equal material and I think it's
not only equal in material terms but
also in terms of the position on this
was this was stupid though rook f8
what's coming on this other couldn't be
two is is okay it couldn't be two is
okay yeah there is some probably am a
draw happening there are various ways to
to to get them for example this this is
a way to get them get a totally equal
endgame yeah of course some it is some
if we go all the way back how exactly is
sweet like going to calculate this
through this route b8 madness yeah it
seems that this is the only move that
that really draws and the thing is we
just looked at Queen III yet there are
also other moves I mean checking and
here you can also look at other moves
for example Bishop g5 is also move that
it first looks really dangerous consider
this check up like a soup yet though and
here it's probably now for white
mandatory to force a draw with rookie 70
can do that okay so with the perpetual
check yeah another another funny line
yeah the the cruel factors here Swilley
I had to find all this rook p8 stuff
over the board and no
this is just incredibly difficult he
played Bishop f6 relatively quickly even
and after Bishop g6 check he now was
forced yeah I think he was forced to
give the Queen I was just thinking
briefly why why not is this actually but
rookie at seven SM is again very strong
King g8 and rook g1 threatening bishop
age five winning the house yeah terribly
complicated stuff he has to take it out
and he he did take it take took the
Bishop Bishop c7 and Bishop g7 yeah and
if we take stock here black has two
minor pieces and the rook for the Queen
materially speaking this is in fact very
good for black the problem is your king
is still in terribly bad shape it is
covered by by many pieces around it so
it's not very likely that black is going
to to get meted very soon but the
combination of threats against the king
and the looseness of black structure
yeah pieces are not covered like g6 and
g7 they're not protected in any way this
combination is very difficult to handle
and this is also why widest is better
however the way kawana is playing the
next couple of moves is really really
great yeah Queen d3 still playing
quickly my GF takes and queenie form
yeah only here he took some time maybe
at this point around here he was out of
his preparation also don't forget that
this villa was thinking all the time
okay Kara wanna played very quickly all
those moves but he had time to recall
his analysis or think um once wiggler
was
was considering what to do Queenie form
is really a very strong move and not a
very apparent one I mean Queen f3 looks
very obvious however after you create
Queen c6 King e7 the game continues it's
not totally decisive for white and he
had a better idea Queenie form is also
attacking the rook needed to move and
now the strong move is 95 this is a very
strong idea it activates the night here
on the on the rim and really shows that
black's pieces are not really well
coordinated black cannot take here
because this is a very vicious double
attack winning immediately and this
means black has a ton of problems night
e six Queens g6 check in connection with
the night joining the joining of the
game I think black is pretty much beyond
saving him very difficult at least the
computer wants to defend Houdini that is
wants to defend with rook h6 giving
white still a substantial plus the
question is is it any better than the
game I think it's it's borderline
between Twitter between lost and and
close to lost I actually think that king
is have not what's wiggler plate it's a
relatively clever move because now
kawana really is fire is forced to find
the only totally convincing move and he
manages to do them if you want an
exercise here you can stop the video and
try to find the move that kawana played
I can warn you though it is not easy and
it's not like yeah a to move or anything
it's a it's really requires some
calculation
um the only hint though think also of
whites back rank is got a somewhat weak
back rankers 11 idea and think also of
the pawn on f3 ok have a look at the
position I'll be silent for a moment so
that you can conveniently pause and
continue and I can actually drink some
coffee um yeah what is the move i'm
going to show you the best movies look
to f1 and this is what Kara wanna also
played by far the strongest move the
thing is the first thing you calculate
is probably night XD 70 luke t 7 and now
white cannot take on e5 as there is a
maid threat white needs to take first
takes here and now look f8 and this is
the problem this is what why it needed
to to to calculate and assess the
problem is this pawn is too strong right
now can can stop this but he will not be
able if you consider that this Bishop is
also coming to the middle of the board
you will not be able to to win the game
yeah also note with the bishop
protecting the pawn there are even
active ideas for black like entering on
g2 it will end in a draw as why it will
probably activate the Queen at the right
moment and then go for some sort of
Perpetual it's in any case not
convincing for white and I guess also by
by the process of elimination he came to
the move rook to f1 and now there is
this red 9725 without the rook hanging
on d1 and black actually does not have
any any reply to that sir quite quite
quite remarkable there is really no way
to save the piece
black can not move the bishop in any way
if we look at this is just creamy signal
six coming and what he did he played
rukka vedas the relatively best defense
after Knight takes rook takes Queen e5
we have a position that is of course
comparable to the one before but now we
select rooks on the board and that's a
big difference as white can use this
rook and the Queen now um yeah in
combination to to build up and create
threats and the problem is if we
continue this for a couple of moves
white went to f2 just stopping the pond
and now why it has some time to to
actually improve his position and what
improvements are there mostly related to
the pawns he has an edge porn that can
be used and as we see a couple of moves
later here you can play on the queenside
and this is the Desai's effector after a
three the combined pressure on before
made black to exchange on a three and
now white also has a see porn yeah in
the concrete position here rooks if
always play to get in the Queen oh this
is discovered actually I'm sorry to get
the Queen into the game maybe with check
see our queen to be six you played
Bishop g5 this is not the most resilient
move Bishop d7 was a bit tougher after
Bishop g5 there was rook c8 yeah and now
black really assess is out of out of any
defense we look for example at Bishop d7
Jack windy for check yeah now where do
you go that's always see for coming also
this is too much why this
check check also operating with which I
check made threats check check check me
just one line at those two pieces just
just kill the king it's it's too much
this means that after Roxy ATM swidler
resigned he didn't find any any play of
a move yeah a remarkable game a very
very complicated game it was very much
influenced by the fact that Caruana was
still in his preparation he's known for
excellent opening preparation of course
while it seems that swidler was called
wrong-footed and needed to to play this
position over the board and this is of
course um yeah a very very difficult
task um I'm not totally sure that this
this kind of position here is it's
really winning for white the computer is
fairly optimistic giving white almost
upon a porn ahead +1 but there may be
still has some resources hidden in this
but ok there is a limited limit of time
that can be invested to to look at those
games if you want to present them couple
of hours after the end of the game it
however seems that at least for the time
being it seems that Ruby hate was the
right defense but how is someone going
to find this over the what i really
don't i really don't blame if like a
black player here um okay it was a
spectacular game interesting game to
look at also the variations i found
after this check i found exceptionally
nice this is this kind of thing this
kind of stuff ending in a draw yeah it's
a it's really remarkable
ok I hope you enjoyed the coverage of
this round to the second round of the
norm a chess tournament and we have
course of course have a very clear
leader now kawana with two wins you want
this benoni this time trouble benoni
against michigan now here with white he
beats Whitlam in this sharp game which
was very large parts of it were based on
preparation but still a strong
performance you have to put in the work
first yeah even if it was done at home
yeah thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed it I'll be back with round three
tomorrow thanks